il va s'en dire que François leg mène
une campagne difficile vous le savez
inutile d'insister très longtemps les
sondages ne sont pas très bon pour la
CAC il doit lui se faire élire dans sa
circonscription de l'Assomption ça avait
été très serré la dernière fois un peu
plus de 1000 voix contre la péquiste à
l'époque et cette fois-ci le Parti
québécois a décidé d'envoyer quelqu'un
de plus connu Pierre Paquet ancien
député du Bloc québécois dans
Joliet les libéraux Jean-Marc Bergevin
François Lego bien sûr et la et Québec
solidaire Sylvain Fournier mon camarade
Jean Sébastien Cloutier s'est promené
dans la circonscription toute la journée
vous avez parlé à des gens vous avez
bien sûr des extraits des deux
principaux
candidat ça sera pas une bataille je le
disais facile pour Monsieur
leg non pas pas du tout inutile de vous
dire qu'il déborde néanmoins de
confiance on a rencontré Monsieur le en
fin d'avant midi à la permanence de la
CAC à Montréal vous allez probablement
voir dans les images qu'il était de
passage dans l'Assomption hier une de
ses rares visites parce que comme chef
il doit parcourir le Québec il est allé
dans un salon de qu a rencontré
plusieurs années d'ailleurs monsieur leg
compte beaucoup d'admirateur parmi les
personnes âgées du comté et Monsieur
paquet lui bon on l' rencontré sur
l'heure du midi son bureau de compter
pas tellement loin d'ici laissez-moi
vous dire qu'il est appuyé par beaucoup
de militants qui
peut-être pas 24 he sur 24 mais qui
passent vraiment leur journée au
téléphone à essayer de convaincre les
gens monsieur pquet a peut-être
l'avantage d'être plus présent sur le
terrain que François leg par contre
François leg dit écoutez les gens c'est
pas compliqué un ancien syndicaliste qui
va encore dépenser et nous mettre encore
plus dans le trou et moi je suis un
homme d'affair qui sait comment gérer
alors bon il revient toujours avec les
mêmes arguments je vous laisse écouter
monsieur leg puis monsieur pquet sur
leur campagne
moi j'ai eu quand même un an et demi à
être là toutes les semaines à faire la
tournée les samedis soirs donc non je
pense que quand on additionne tout là
j'ai été beaucoup plus présent auprès
des gens de l'Assomption que Pierre
parquet qui est tout nouveau qui habite
pas le coin donc non ça ça m'inquiète
pas puis écoutez je vous le dis là je
pense que l'Assomption les gens on a
développer une relation spéciale c'est
une campagne terrain alors je profite du
fait que Monsieur leg malheureusement
pour lui doit être à l'extérieur de la
circonscription pour être vraiment
rencontrer les gens dans les commerces
chez eux faire le plus de de de visites
d'entreprise possible qu'on a une
mobilisation puis je pense que vous le
voyez qui est très forte je suis j'en ai
fait beaucoup d'élections mais je peux
vous dire j'ai rarement vu un degré de
mobilisation si important il y a des
gens aussi de l'extérieur qui viennent
nous donner un coup de main Jean
Sébastien je le disais vous êtes promené
aujourd'hui dans la circonscription
l'Assomption insulpiss très beau coin
vous avez pu parler à des gens également
oui rien de scientifique on a rencontré
un peu plus de partisans de François leg
que de Pierre Paquette sauf que la
perception qu'on a c'est que les
militants qui favorisent François leg
sont quand même un peu plus inquiets par
rapport à ceux qui pensent que Monsieur
paquet va gagner eux ils sont à peu près
convaincus que Pierre Paquet sera élu
faut dire que la région ici est bleue
depuis longtemps Jacques Pariso avait
été élu en 94 avec 11000 voix de
majorité ça a voté à 63 % pour le oui
lors du référendum c'est un coin
péquiste et à travers ça ben il y a C
cette pas cette vague mais dans les
sondages on sent que les libéraux
montent d'ailleurs Pierre Paquet le
disait qu'il le sentait aussi sur le
terrain et selon lui bah les gens qui
vont favoriser les libéraux proviennent
plutôt des rangs caquiss ce qui pourrait
l'aider dit-il je laisse écouter
quelques électeurs rencontrés très bien
oui monsieur leg pourquoi parce que je
pour la caque pour tout ce que qui pense
pu pour les générations futures puis je
crois que c'est lui qui a le plus de
potentiel pour ça je trouve que Monsieur
leg a fait un très bon travail pour ici
là dans dans dans la dans les dernières
années il était quand même
impliqué monsieur paquet je pense qu'il
pourrait faire un très bon travail aussi
là je me suis renseigné à ses propos
mais je sais pas encore vers qui je vais
me pencher honnêtement à L'Assomption on
a toujours été Parti québécois donc il y
a une vague la dernière fois ici mais
tout simplement ça va revenir au Parti
québécois vous pensez que Monsieur
paquet va gagner tout à fait pourquoi
parce que c'est une meilleur j'aime
beaucoup le niveau de de critique de
Monsieur Couillard parce que il descend
jamais à mon avis en dessous de la
ceinture vous avz peut-être voté pour le
candidat libéral peut-être peut-être
peut-être alors voilà quand vous posez
la question aux gens de quoi vous
aimeriez qu'on vous parle dans cette
campagne les enjeux dans la
circonscription
l'économie c'est certain électroluxe ça
vous dit sûrement quelque chose 1300
personnes vont perdre leur emploi au
printemps ici à L'Assomption c'est
énorme c'était des emplois bien
rémunérés sinon ici c'est la MRC où il y
a à peu près le plus gros boom
démographique de tout le Québec avec la
bon la couronne éloignée de Montréal le
450 beaucoup de gens viennent de vivre
ici tour de natalité également très
élevé alors les infrastructure ont de la
difficulté à suivre le la hausse de la
population alors mettre à niveau les
services en santé on est ucation et
cetera je laisse à nouveau écouter
François leg et Pierre
Paquet il faut être capable de
reconnaître qu' un problème perd 1300
emplois à 25 dollars de l'URE chez
elctrolux là on aurait dû s'en occuper
puis on c depuis 3 4 ans donc c'est pas
seulement un problème d'inaction du
gouvernement du PQ mais aussi du
gouvernement du Parti libéral donc c'est
certain moi je vais porter ce dossierlà
sera votre principal cheval de bataille
ben il y en a deux je c'est l'emploi
c'est sûr pour être capable de de de de
de corriger le trou que va laisser le
départ d'électrolux mais aussi que
l'ensemble des infrastructures publiques
santé éducation les infrastructures
routière suivent la croissance de la
population de la MRC de laassomption qui
a plus que doublé en 10
ans en conclusion Patrice vous dire que
les travailleurs d'électrolux ne sont
pas très contents de la façon dont le
gouvernement a géré le le dossier pas
plus que le PQ que que les libéraux cela
dit un travailleur me disait quand même
qu'il croyait que Pierre Paquet serait
élu quoi qu'il en soit et Pierre Paquet
et François leg sont bien appréciés ici
il y a personne qui nous a parlé en mal
de et les gens vont beaucoup voter je
parlais de de la rive sud hier à
Montarville 88 % de participation mais
dans ce coinl également ça a été à 83 80
80 bon ben voilà ou 80 % ouis et du
monde il y en a parce que après
repentigi ça s'est tellement développé
que ça rejoint
saintsulpis les les nouvelles bâtis les
maisons et C donc très pe PL alors voilà
c'est intéressant de vous entendre
merci
merciat